[Music]
media mogul tyler perry
i like saying medium mogul i'm going to
say it again media mogul tyler ferry
that's what he is is raising awareness
about the coronavirus vaccine
and a new special for bet which is owned
by the way by viacom cbs
this is video of the filmmaker getting
the first dose grady health system in
atlanta approached tyler perry to get
the shot to help get the word out
black americans if you've heard are
disproportionately affected by the virus
and one in three think about that or
hesitant about getting this vaccine
perry's new special aims to provide the
facts about it and in this clip
he talks with grady health system dr
kimberly manning
i'm hearing people say they either don't
want it or that they're going to wait to
get it
if you want to wait to be able to you
know come into community to go to your
family reunion
to be able to do the things that get us
back to living um i think those are
things to consider and i've been saying
you know my loved ones this about us
yeah you know this is about us
the folks that are really taking the
hardest hit are the people that are in
your contacts in your cell phone if you
look like us
boy tyler perry joins us first on cbs
this morning to discuss good to see you
mr perry
let's get started so much to talk to you
about were you reluctant
to take the vaccine yourself before the
doctors at grady health system
approached you
well when doctor del rio and kim
believed dr manning when they called up
and asked if i would take it to
encourage the community i thought i i i
would do that but you've got to answer
all my questions and i thought well
while you answer my question why don't
we record it
so you can answer questions for a lot of
people in the community so yeah i was
skeptical because
if you look at our history in this
country with the tuskegee experiment
henrietta lacks and things like that it
it it raises flags for us
as african-american people so i
understand why there's a healthy
skepticism about the vaccine i
understand why they reached out to you i
know you're
certainly younger than 65 but they
thought if tyler perry gets it it'll
send a strong
message what questions did you have for
the doctors i'm curious give me your top
two what did you
want to know from them well i wanted to
understand the technology i mean we
talked about everything from the
spanish lieu of 1918 to what is
happening now to where it came from
but i think my top question was
understanding mrna technology
and dr kimberly manning and dr del rio
did an amazing job
at explaining that and how this new
technology has helped
to come up with the vaccine so quickly
because when you when i heard things
like warp speed i was really concerned
because
this last administration and all the
pressure they were putting on the cdc
and fda
i don't know i didn't really feel like i
could trust it but once i got all the
information
found out the researchers i was very
very happy
tyler it's anthony mason uh one kaiser
health has done a study
uh in the early days of the vaccine
rollout and i mean it
it bearing out what we've been talking
about the fact that there's a distrust
here
black americans are being vaccinated at
a dramatically lower rate which is
really alarming
so what do you what do you think needs
to be done here to to
to build confidence exactly what we're
doing especially that i'm doing for bet
and asking having an opportunity to ask
experts questions
the first ebola patient in uh in america
was at emory hospital so i got the top
uh experts here in town dr del rio is an
epidemiologist who was brilliant
and to be able to ask those questions
and not only for myself but share them
with the community
you know i've got a people who love what
i do and kind of follow me so
i think once they get the information
that it'll help them and what i told
them is that
i'm not taking this vaccine because i
want you to take it i want
i want to give you the information so
you can make your own choices so i think
that's what it's about education and
information
you know they always talk about the
reaction that's another thing people are
afraid of i've heard number one which
vaccine did you get tyler
i took the visor i took my first one on
the january 4th and i took the second
one yesterday and uh
i had no reaction the first the first
shot this shot that i just took
yesterday i woke up with some aches and
pains but
i took some advil a few about an hour
ago and i still find them
yeah but they said it's very common that
you know you don't have a reaction to
the first one but you can have a
sometimes dramatic reaction to the
second one but it
it doesn't deter you you just still
don't regret taking it right
not at all because here's the
alternative here's what you don't
understand
the problem with this cover 19 virus is
that you never know how it's going to
affect you
and we have i've had people who have
died that i know i've had people who
have had long-term health issues that i
know
so i the va so it you're making the
choice of
getting a vaccine and and even though
it's 95 96
efficacy what happens is you you are
reducing your chances of ending up in
the icu by 100
yeah so i think that's just important
that people know that that
that you don't if you take your chances
with covert you never know how it's
going to affect you and it could affect
your long-term tyler you're absolutely
right we can talk about side effects but
we shouldn't forget the main effect
which is that protection against kobe
19.
uh and when we're talking about
reactions i'm actually interested in the
reaction to you
as you engage with people online and as
you talk with people in the community
where you are
have you succeeded with convincing
anyone in particular that's been
important to you
and what was that experience like that
conversion of going okay they're
skeptical but listen to me
this is good for you and then they make
a change well i tell you this is why the
special that we're doing on bt on
thursday night is so important because
i have a crew that works for me and and
they're largely african-american people
who are all skeptical about the vaccine
when they sat in the room as they were
working the cameras and doing hair and
makeup and all that stuff they listened
to all the information by the time we
got to the end of it they all wanted to
take it
so i think again it just goes back to
getting the correct information
and getting it from people that you
trust and you understand i think this
last administration did a
lot of damage in in eroding trust
when they came when it comes to this
vaccine but the information that i found
has been very helpful listen i'm just
saying i know medea's retired but if
there ever was a time for media to weigh
in on this subject
seems like she would have something to
say i'm getting that damn vaccine i'm
getting that damn dancing
that's the thing people believe medea
because medea
always speaks the truth but let's let's
talk about tyler perry because the
oscars are coming up you were getting
the
humanitarian award whoa congratulations
bravo
what did that mean to you tyler when you
heard you were you were going to get
that you see the list of people have
received that and now
your name is added to the list i love
this i was completely shocked by that
because you know the thing about a gayle
is this
where there is a need and i have the
ability i just want to show up so to see
uh being me being honored with the green
hershey humanitarian award that's that's
beyond moving and i'm so thankful to the
academy for it so
i can't wait it's gonna be a lot of fun
it doesn't get any bigger than that
tyler you made a point of of
of uh announcing that you were flying
back to your home state to vote in the
georgia runoff election
uh that you're glad you did now huh
yeah for sure listen i still don't have
the absentee ballot
you're still going to get it on december
4th we are still waiting for it
still waiting for it i'm glad i came
back yeah you because you the reason
the reason you went back was you you
applied for an absentee ballot but you
said as you said you never came
but stacey abrams gave you some advice
yeah and it was really simple she said
just show up and can't tell him you want
to cancel your your uh
your absentee i walked in i had to sign
after david and i voted in person there
wasn't a line and it all worked out but
yeah
i'll let you know when that absentee
ballot shows up well let me tell you
tyler very curious as somebody who's
done a little reporting on vote by mail
it probably is never coming that thing
is gone but your vote counted so that's
all that matters uh you know talk about
other votes there's a vote coming up in
the senate uh in a couple weeks
uh or probably more than that actually
when the trial starts in the impeachment
of president trump former president
trump
i'm just curious the more we learn about
the
siege on the capitol on january 6 the
worse it seems i'm interested in your
journey both your reaction on the day
of that riot and then how your thinking
has changed as we've learned more in the
days have gone on
you listen it's beyond heartbreaking to
watch to see so many people
seize the capital one capital that
slaves built right
that that you got you've got these
confederate flags walking through where
slaves
actually built this this capital and for
me my
my it was heartbreaking on so many
levels because i believe in america that
it's more inclusive than that that we
all can send that we can disagree
and still move forward in what we're
doing as a country so to see that kind
of division to see what happened there
i i shocking beyond heartbreaking i'm
glad it's over
and i'm glad we're moving toward healing
and i really i really hope that that's
what's going to happen here
you know prince harry and meghan markle
have a podcast you were one of their
first guests you always do this
you don't even know what i'm gonna ask
you you don't even know
i mean okay they have a podcast you were
on it
and you said at the time for 2020 you
were handling it one day at a time
and with prayer so i'm wondering what is
your wish for 2021 i wasn't going to ask
you no personal questions about harry
and megan
i was asking you about this well you
know my son
my son six years old he wrote a
beautiful letter last night he said
dear mr uh mr president and mr vice
president please
make sure that everyone has access to
poop i thought that was really amazing
right so
so he's clearly got this gene from me
and my mom and just all the stuff of
helping
so my hope my hope is that we all do
what people what is what we need to for
the
stimulus package to get the people in
need what they need so that we can fix
this pandemic we're going through all
right tyler perry thank you very much
how's harry megan doing i'll see you
later i'll see you later
i love your snooze by the way man i love
you thank you very much i appreciate it
bye tyler thank you so much thank you
thank you
soon bye-bye you can watch this
coronavirus special on b-e-t and b-e-t
her this thursday night i love all
things tyler perry